hey everyone welcome to Simply LS
YouTube channel today we will learn
about descriptive statistics in Excel
that's said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
like And subscribe buttons and the bell
icon to get notified just for a quick
info if you want to upscale yourself
master business analytics skills and
learn your dream job or growing your
career then you must explore simply Lear
go of various business analytics
programs simply offers postgraduate
program from per University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft through this program you can
gain knowledge and work ready expertise
in skills like prescriptive and
Predictive Analytics regression
classification and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts and Top
Tire product companies and academic from
top universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a business analytic
role as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job profile if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comment and description box
below to find out a business analytics
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest it started with the
demonstration for today's session so
descriptive statistics in Excel so
firstly what exactly is descriptive
statistics in Excel so some of the
functions like central tendency me
median measure of variability mode range
box plot Etc such kind of functions are
called as descriptive statistics
functions now let's say you find a data
set in which you are supposed to find
the descriptive statistic values of that
particular DD set and you have to write
down all the functions manually right if
you want to eliminate that big task that
huge task then there is a simple
shortcut method in Excel but how can we
do that that's exactly what we're going
to do discussed today in this session so
let's get back to the Practical mode I
will open Microsoft Excel so this
particular file is my input file for
today's session so I have about 10 to 15
decimal values like whole numbers in
know complete uh let's say this is the
not the whole numbers these are the
decimal values which we are going to
discuss for today so let's say these are
the input values for us for today and we
are supposed to find out the uh
descriptive statistics for all these
numbers right which is a mean value
average value etc etc and which is a
simple shortcut method to do that right
now let's select the values and go to
data and here okay we have water of
analysis so by default we will not have
that here so go to developer options and
in this developer options go to Excel
addit and here you can see analysis tool
PK let's click okay on that and I think
I'll be able to add it now so when you
go back to data again here you can find
some option called Data an analysis
right word of analysis is been pushed a
little to the left so now you have data
analysis click on that and uh in a
moment you have the options here click
on descriptive statistics press okay
there you go now you have the input
range give this particular input range
to your file and uh now you have the
data in columns so columns by default
and uh yeah you can either create a new
worksheet you can either create a new
workbook right I will go with new
worksheet or you can click the output
range over here and here you can get the
value I'll give a cell value here I'll
give
D1 and I think everything else is good
to go in case if you want the summary
statistics confidence level right and K
the largest K smallest you can also give
that and press okay and there you go you
will have all the values here just
expand the rows I mean yeah expand the
columns and you will have all the values
vales you need and with that we have
come to an end of this session on
descriptive statistics in Excel if you
have any queries regarding any of the
topics covered in this session please do
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts we'll be more
than happy to assist you at the earliest
until next time thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from Simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the descript description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here